for more on the Capitol Hill healthcare
showdown we're joined from our
Washington bureau by Rachel bade
congressional reporter for Politico
Rachel good morning good morning so we
now know Senator McCain says that he
will not vote for this and it looks like
Republicans are once again one vote shy
of falling short of that 50 that they
need is there a chance that this
legislation doesn't even go for a vote
hit the floor there's absolutely a
chance of that Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell I was very careful when
he said last week that they were going
to vote on this this week he said he
would he intended to put the bill to the
floor however if he doesn't have the
votes it's unlikely that he's gonna make
his conference take that tough vote
again and put them on the spot I would
just say that McCain basically killed
the cat that had nine lives right I mean
how many times have we heard talk about
Obamacare repeal bill the Obamacare
repeal being dead we heard this in the
house in the spring all throughout the
summer in the Senate and once again
McCain is coming out and saying he won't
vote for this susan collins is probably
not gonna vote for this she's a moderate
she's never been big about repealing
also Rand Paul saying it doesn't go far
enough in terms of repealing Obamacare
so what you have here is about three
senators who are gonna block this now
the difference this time is that
lawmakers really only have one week to
do this because their ability to do this
on a party-line basis expires at the end
of September and so while everybody said
repeal was done repeal was done and then
they continued working on it now they're
actually running up against the clock
Rachel how does this legislation
actually differ from the last well
that's what a lot of people are saying
they have deja vu right now and yes this
bill is different it doesn't repeal as
much of Obamacare but it block grants
money to the states and allows them to
do whatever they want with that money
but the thing is a lot of the concerns
are very much the same and that is why
people are saying they're sort of giving
deja vu right so you have conservatives
who want to go a little further to the
right and you have centrist and moderate
Republicans who are concerned that
people in their states are going to be
kicked off Medicare low-income folks who
can't afford health care and they're
worried about that backlash you have a
lot of Republicans traditional
Republicans and also moderates who are
concerned about people with pre-existing
conditions
and basically are you know worried that
this bill is going to allow insurance
companies to charge sicker people more
than healthier people and so I think
that a lot of the debate is the same and
that's why this bill didn't really go
anywhere and that last concern is one of
the things that we've heard from
talk-show host Jimmy Kimmel he's been
out very much against this bill right
now seeing someone like that weigh in
does that have an impact in Washington
usually I would say celebrities do not
but this instance it does because
pre-existing conditions are really
important to people in terms of
protecting Rachael bade thank you very
much for being with us this morning
thank you absolutely